800.000 besucher darunter auch viele
touristen zeigten sich am
nationalfeiertag beeindruckt von der
leistungsschau des österreichischen
bundesheeres in wien
die veranstaltung stand ganz im zeichen
des mottos unser heer sorgt für ihre
sicherheit
der erste programmpunkt am
nationalfeiertag war die angelobung der
neuen rekruten im beisein der
bundesregierung eltern und freunde waren
sichtlich stolz auf die jungen soldaten
ich habe nie einen zweifel daran
gelassen in den letzten jahren und
jahrzehnten dass ich den stellenwert des
bundesheers sehr hoch einschätze das ist
in der verfassung vorgeschrieben das ist
für unsere neutralität für unsere
sicherheit für unsere grenzen für den
katastrophenschutz wichtig und der
heutige tag ist ein tag wo sich das
bundesheer präsentiert und ich finde bei
den leuten sehr viel interesse und
positive reaktionen
gleiches galt auch für die soldaten vor
ort die sichtlich erfreut waren über den
besuch des präsidenten bei seinem
rundgang über das gelände
elf themeninseln gab es zu erkunden
schutz und hilfe standen dabei im
vordergrund
wir bemühen uns nationalfeiertag
das breite leistungsspektrum des
österreichischen bundesheeres der
öffentlichkeit zugängig zu machen und
wir haben verschiedenste direkte
vorführungen und elemente aufgebaut aber
klar ist dass es gerade im inland die
katastrophenhilfe als jene hin lanz
aufgabe ist die natürlich die breiteste
wirkung und auch das wichtigste element
für die bevölkerung darstellt nicht ganz
so publikumswirksam aber dennoch wichtig
ist der schutz der bevölkerung ist das
was wir eigentlich kurz unter
militärische landesverteidigung bestehen
schutz der lebensgrundlagen der
bevölkerung schutz der kritischen
infrastruktur im fall der bedrohung aber
auch schutz der verfassungsmäßigen
einrichtungen und demokratischen
freiheiten bei einwohnern eine der
neuesten schutzeinrichtungen ist das
zelt system crm pro das in dieser
konfiguration 16 personen fasst
vorstädter kollektiv protection sprich
der schutz des kollektivs also dass die
personen im innenraum geschützt sind
das passiert über die sogenannten abc
atomar biologischen und chemischen
filtration anlagen der die frischluft
von außenanlagen in den zellen innenraum
blasen und dadurch baut sie im zelt
immer über druck auf und dadurch mehr
saubere luft von innen nach außen stadt
anstatt was wir von außen schmutzige
luft also kontaminierte luft in den
innenraum hinein
die besucher zeigten sich allgemein sehr
interessiert den kleinsten waren wir
immer von den schweren geräten und der
technik beeindruckt den großen hingegen
gefiel das rahmenprogramm und die
einzelnen stationen wie kampf davon ja
kommando waren sehr interessant
die habe ich da noch nicht gesehen
gehabt wir waren im zelt erinnern von
den salzburger pionieren was auch
interessant war die kinder sahen wir uns
von bourbon unterkommen andere
versicherer kinos immer da der
attraktionen 18 gleich ganze sache wenn
ich sehr gut fand heraus alles gut
organisiert
mir gefällt grundsätzlich sehr gut dass
man einmal einen einblick bekommt was
das bundesheer so leistet wir haben zwei
spezielle highlights als programmpunkte
heuer extra dazu genommen
das ist erst einmal die auszeichnung des
militär des jahres ganz einfach die
besten des österreichischen bundesheers
und als zweites großes highlight haben
wir sportlicher sicht im rahmen der
attraktivierung des grundwehrdienstes
das große finale im fußball eine art
straßenfußball auf hohem niveau
vor wochen schon wurden die meister bei
den brigaden ermittelt glorreicher
sieger war letztendlich das team vom
villacher pionierbataillon 1 der
höhepunkt des tages war allerdings die
prämierung zum militär des jahres in
drei kategorien zivilbedienstete des
jahres wurde amtsdirektor werner kern
meyer als einheit des jahres wurde das
aufklärungs artilleriebataillon vier
ausgezeichnet für seinen einsatz im
kosovo und als soldat des jahres
zeichnete man hauptmann peter wittenberg
von der abc abwehrschule aus ich habe
diesen preis für meinen einsatz bei der
oecd im rahmen der chemiewaffen
vernichtung in syrien bekommen
es ist diese kombination
aushelfen für bevölkerung im in und
ausland in dem fall ist er um die uns
ausland gegangen und um den soldatischen
fähigkeiten und die zeichnen das
österreichische bundesheer allgemein aus
engagiert und kompetent zeigten sich die
soldaten auch im gespräch mit der
bevölkerung die stolz ist auf das wissen
und die einsatzbereitschaft des
österreichischen bundesheers